I think as a human being we may they
always have a sense of a right or wrong
except in in certain kind of society
force under certain kinda education
those those very often those judgment
those value judgment has been tasted or
her has been changed so my father that's
why being a individual as a poet or
artists are important because it
disassociate with this type of education
it always almost like innocent in the
way to make make a clear judgment based
on very simple right or wrong judgment
but we often see in the society even in
very sophisticated society like today
people are not making those plant
judgment which as I think it's a tragic
or intellectual state of mind not to ask
in the question right or wrong to kill
idea is most important design q-flash or
body for those dictators they don't like
even the attitude like why Saudi have to
kill journalists saying Turkish embassy
you know that's the question we have to
ask her today why we know that happen we
all know that the whole Western world
know that and we think that's okay to
kill journalists singing in Turkish
embassy we pretend nothing's happening
and we wanna ask her the since happened
a years ago today
why can you tell me why
the killing or why we accept no I mean
person you know the recent recalls the
kanata allowed different attitude the
arc is the writers certainly form a very
different attitude that's most dangerous
to dictators a dictatorship that's more
powerful than any weapon but art is
always related to human spirit and the
human humans consciousness or inner
truth and as well always stay with us is
so it definitely we have a lot to do
always well as long as human exist
Arta would always be a part of it a
quote from you for artists and
intellectuals today while this
much-needed is to be clear about social
responsibility because that's what
people automatically give up why this
sense of responsibility why is it that
you demand from artists and
intellectuals today to be clear about
social responsibility
i I I think as an individual or as
artists more as artists your your work
the nippon nature of your work is about
expression express yourself and to also
about stand up some kind of
communication so so your work so that
comes as this is a social responsibility
because you're you are express certain
ideas or you can call it beauty or
choose and under you believe in that and
and you also believe that would benefit
others for me my own my so-called social
response is a personal struggle it's
it's a way I have to testing my
to find out how how certain says it to
find out my true religions which outside
the world it's not it's very totally
selfish purpose to to find out those I
have a strong curiosity about my Who I
am Who am I and how I would respond to
those issues only by doing that I
realize Who I am I it's not really about
courage but rather about curiosity how a
individual can react to a situation
you